[Applaudissements]
grandes écoles d'ingénieurs où le nombre
études de mon choix
certificat d'études primaires
corps gepi la vie par les deux bouts à
minutes de conversation l'a jamais fait
fois les valeurs familiales mais surtout
est loin d'être le lieu du parcours de
en 2006
je vais vous parler de comment ce
de filles guinéennes se compter au bout
ayez confiance à vos rêves
une remarque assez singulière
désespoir
m'inspirant de cet héritage de force et
des doigts
jusque là tout va très bien dans ma vie
la force de ne jamais abandonner
rêve
et dima de moins c'est ce que je vais
j'accède de docks a lancé m je poursuis
de son côté le comité de murphy soulagée
redoutable comité a transformé ma vie
quand le savoir cette femme venait de me
a été un coup dur je vous assure et pour
de courage profond
le monde semblait faire mes pieds tout
vous dire risque de vous choquer et ne
semmam célèbre la victoire
et c'est en cela que je voudrais attirer
voilà donc en 2007 j'arrive à la bio
lancer un défi
comment à travers les adeptes du comité
mes trois années de formation
le prenez pas autrement je préfère être
paraît si facile fille à papa j'ai tous
d'ingénieur au bout desquels je prie
rejeté cette fois ci est à relever
moi pour ma part je dois avouer que ça a
tout vous dire après tous les efforts
pour poursuivre mes études je m'inscris
franc avec vous votre projet est un peu
l'attention sur l'importance d'une chose
les droits
de murphy et appuie l'importance de la
aime brillamment mon diplôme en
que j'ai fournis au cours de mon cursus
brillant à l'école j'étais très proche
au lycée public rue gouraud je vais
été l'échec le plus cuisant pour moi
actualité finance et je décroche un
et l'éducation
contre vents et marées à détermination à
trop ambitieux pourquoi je dis cela
persévérance
académique j'ai vécu cette expérience
emploi à casablanca
de mon père
passer deux années parsemées d'embûches
la patience et de la bi négation
cours d'eau ce cursus académique
car voyez-vous bien que la fois le
surmonter tous les obstacles devant
à lattes de turbulences familiales le
fois dans ma quête perpétuelle de
je rêvais à mon enfance de devenir
reste assez jeune
comme étant un échec total
ampères pour sa mémoire et pour les
cette deuxième voie était juste
pilier n'était plus là aux difficultés
connaissances je décide de contenir les
et appris l'art de transformer les
pilote comme notre regretté dans binta
vous êtes célibataire et vous êtes
de tout genre
études en france
inégalable il était hors de question
courage l'abnégation
et donc après plusieurs requêtes de
difficultés en opportunité la nécessité
pilote qui m'inspire beaucoup
efforts que j'ai consenti pour y arriver
à me retrouver à marcher sur des
et encore une autre étape à franchir
pour moi que le comité de ma fille et
et était le carburant et a permis de
d'origine africaine
réorientation que les autorités
réseaux cette fois
de se réinventer quand il le faut et
relève est vraiment de conquérir le
mais c'est aussi cela qui m'a permis de
avec son lot de difficultés bien
kilomètres et des kilomètres on habite
venir à bout de ce long périple
consulaires ont réussi à me convaincre
surtout arrêt de ne jamais abandonner
et donne travaillé d'arrache-pied durant
évidemment
monde et comme tout enfant de mon âge
un volet call matin midi et soir pour
effectivement au fond de moi j'étais
force est de reconnaître que le navire
d'aller suivre les cours cette première
tenir les adeptes de merfy à distance
partir de mes maigres économies issues
j'étais persuadé de l'arrivée avec mes
très choquée d'ailleurs la personne qui
année la dalle écoles professionnelles à
mes deux premières années en
du voyage a été et demeure l'éducation
cette nouvelle aspects négatifs du sujet
je pense qu'un parti c'est grâce à cet
mathématiques appliquées pour réunir
de mes primes de stages et de mon
parents à mes côtés
me promettant que je pourrais changer
m'avait accompagné
rendre à l'école
tout ce qu'il me fallait pour accéder au
salaire pour le peu de temps que j'ai
un livre dans lequel mes parents m'ont
dé j'ai fait les foires d'afficher un
pour me réorienter vers la médecine
mais croyez moi que tout au long de mon
événement que je suis là aujourd'hui
delà des écoles d'ingénieurs
hélas
travaillé à casablanca
avait tellement appris à marcher vite et
l'année suivante
intervention nous allons découvrir
placé depuis ma tendre enfance et dans
je débarque en france sans aucun soutien
devant vous
c'est le moment de passer le concours
au 2 mai 13 ans que pour la première
sourire et je leur point de vue ono
ensemble l'identité de ce fameux comitié
à la fin de l'année je reviens donc avec
au bout du rouleau
approché j'ai appelé une connaissance
lequel je prends plaisir à rester
financier
messieurs ne vous en faites pas je ne
j'étais tellement constante sur la route
à travers mon propre vécu certains parmi
qu'il avait tenté à l'époque pour avoir
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours
fois
je me suis élevé en partie grâce au
et j'avais des cours intense dans deux
de beaux résultats comme il m'a été
archives à faire son apparition dans ma
suis pas choqué c'est que vous venez de
tous les jours l ajournement quartier -
quelques conseils et indications sur
demandé la sema demande de changement de
vous si les connaître pour avoir déjà
je suis convaincu
dire a le mérite d'être honnête c'est
vie avec sa fille chez loi qui prédit
soutien de ma famille et de mes amis
cette personne sensée m'encourager m'a
filière
écoles différentes dans le cadre d'une
été confrontés aux actions du même
surnommé tgv
est passé
une réalité je combine tous les critères
que tout ce qui est susceptible d'aller
comité et je suis persuadé qu'au bout du
double diplômation ce qui ne me
l'éducation la bonne est le moteur de
donc c'est quand je passais que je les
mal qu'il a mal
dit en rigolant nous avons déjà tenté ce
le comité de marché comme il en existe
lorsque j'ai réalisé que la médecine
discriminants pour réaliser un tel
permettait pas d'alliés études et
premier coup fatal à liv
concours et avons échoué mais comme toi
voyage il ne sera plus nécessaire de
n'était plus possible
entends qu à chaque fois dire le tgv
toujours et partout était bien en place
projet
travail comme la plupart des étudiants
démontrer pourquoi il ne faut jamais
que je maintiens que les intelligences
un moment donné j'ai voulu abandonner
tout développement
et je vous propose de re parler
arrive
en france
et c'est dans ce sens que mes amis et
abandonner dans la vie
diffère du ferrat peut-être l'exception
et arrivera jamais mais j'étais à ses
je n'avais pas le puits de taxi moto
les études par la suite
a donc fallu faire avec la galère et je
tranquillement autour d'un café une fois
et vous êtes prêts un des mares
moi
adhérents à la face
pour aller à l'école
un pilier le pilier de toute la famille
avons voulu apporter notre modeste
que le projet aura abouti
aux mets de man est-ce que vous avez des
j'ai pensé à revenir ici en guinée pour
avoue que cette réaction me refroidit
je n'avais pas aussi les moyens de me
vous dis la vraie galère pendant la
là jamais regardé me dit vous avez l'air
et dans les profondeurs du fouta djalon
d'ailleurs
contribution à l'éducation des jeunes
parents qui peuvent effectuer les
j'ai commencé à me poser des questions
faire la médecine ou aller voir le
payer les cours de révision pour
guinéens et globalement africains à
démarches pour vous au pays
période de ma formation
je suis la fille d'un homme à la craie
sénégal j'étais complètement perdu
d'être sûr de vous ensuite je lui
j'ai même failli baisser les bras
à répondre à l'appel de dieu à la veille
travers le ng colibri afic et
préparer mon baccalauréat
très curieuse comme question d'autant
et d'une femme à la marmite
pour tout vous dire depuis ce jour là je
demande tout ce qu'il me fallait comme
résumer mon parcours a été tumultueux
c'est ma soeur aînée que je remercie au
plus que la formation se passe au maroc
satarov le bonne volonté mais les
de mon admission
l'éducation au coeur de ses priorités
la tradition familiale n'échappe pas à
craignais maintenant de demander
document pour la suite de la procédure
passage qui a refusé que j'abandonne les
mais interné par là est-ce que j'ai
conseils car je savais que c'était un
accords d gratuitement parce que je
à travers cette gêne des ong nous avons
est mon ami et moi on s'en va
la force d'un homme je suis issu d'une
et vous certes seulement qu'à 13 ans je
travaillais bien à l'école
rendez vous garantis avec le redoutable
études à l'époque elle m'a encouragé à
famille très nombreuse
confrontés à d'énormes difficultés de la
au comité de murphy
une famille avec de gros moyens
lorsque le projet a abouti
entre autres puis réhabilité
malgré toutes ces difficultés
enfin
rester au maroc et à poursuivre mes
est d'ailleurs décidé de me cacher pour
vie
partiellement au lycée d'origine dans un
financiers ou alors avec des relations
me retrouve déchu de
et réussi à décrocher mon baccalauréat
études
j'aurais pu abandonner à plusieurs
n'avons pas eu l'occasion d'en reparler
passer le concours pour caucau je ne
nous comme dans la plupart des familles
perles le sourire au soleil disparaît
état très délabré
je vais donc pour imaginer je devrai
replacer ou tout simplement des
unique option sciences expérimentales en
reprises 6 me résigner aux sages
nous avons mis en place au niveau
autour d'un café comme on l'aurait voulu
personnes qui pourrait régler la facture
traditionnelles africaines ont dit plus
réussirais pas que personne ne soit au
2009 à l'âge de saison
j'ai l'impression que le monde
maintenant parcours
conseils du comité de ma fille qui ne
à conakry afin que ma situation soit
contenu delà de la pandémie mais nous
on est nombreux plus on à la chasse
courant de mon échec cela m'éviterait
national une bourse d'excellence pour
s'effondre autour de moi
sont sans doute pas les plus motivateur
et je fus parmi les as du pays
le décide alors de bifurquer vers une
comme d'entre nous sortent du lot c'est
examiné un rabbin
des commentaires comme oncle avait dit
accompagner les jeunes et de la deuxième
avons eu une discussion au téléphone à
ont choisi d'aller au bout de mes rêves
la très timide à l'époque ma timidité
à dire qu'un d'entre nous réussissent
pas très bonne question dans mon cas
autre voie totalement différente les
on avait prévu on savait de la part des
édition s'est elle a lancé d'ailleurs
donc une bourse d'études pour le maroc
ce sujet là et en avons bien rigolé
s'accentue ferland fermé sur moi même
de tombola à l'africaine pour constituer
parce que je n'avais pas
mathématiques appliquées
bientôt
membres du comité de murphy
aujourd'hui c'est un portable complaire
alors vous l'aurez peut-être deviné
et figurez-vous bien que le comité de
la famille
le comité de ma fille va me faire
contente je pars au maroc dans le but de
dans ma situation
est derrière cette peur vivait à moins
moi c'est le début d'un véritable voyage
là la famille classique africaine de
je mène ma petite vie qui me permet
comprendre
offert simple le fameux comité de ma
murphy sera au rendez vous comme à
que si je n'ai pas de parents bien placé
faire la médecine comme le souhaitait
une détermination sans faille
qui est celui de la vie
d'être plus ou moins une fille
l'accoutumée
nous tous si si plaisant sommes fiers
mon défunt père parce qu'il faut le dire
fille c'est ce groupe fictif fictif de
de soi sur parfaite de cela va venir
il ne sert à rien de se battre je n'y
que même si moi depuis ma tendre enfance
à mon plus grand soulagement
je vais désormais apprendre à affronter
et la chance très tôt d'aller à l'école
gens qui sont toujours là à vous
d'une dame qui travaillait à l'époque à
et la chance de travailler
arriverai pas la médecine il faut
la vie certes pas toute seule parce que
assigner un blocage mental
j'atteignais cet objectif qui semblait à
l'ambassade de guinée au maroc qui
j'ai rêvé de devenir pilote mon père lui
l'oublier tout simplement
grandes multinationales
chance que n'ont pas tous les enfants
qui sont toujours là à vous transmettre
j'avais le reste de ma famille et je
lorsque j'ai décidé de me réorienter en
bien des égards hors de portée
voulait que je devienne médecin compte
donc après plusieurs semaines de
nés dans des endroits reculés du pays
la chance de beaucoup réagir mais comme
des ondes négatives dans vos rêves dans
maths appliquées va me faire comprendre
réalisais que rien n'était plus comme
et figurez vous que la dame de la
tenu des circonstances je tenais à lui
démarches administratives
mon père était instituteur
avant
sarcastiquement devant tout le monde que
armes de tension avec les autorités de
vous aurez pu le noter la vie n'a pas
vos initiatives dans vos projets et
mossade dont je vous ai parlé célèbre le
faire honneur à la surface à volonté
la mort de mon père a été une preuve
il tenait qu'à même à ce que tous ces
même du comité de marchi qu'avaient
toujours été tendre avec moi et
c'était non seulement impossible mais
entreprises
l'ambassade et les autorités services de
mais une fois au royaume chérifien
prédit - échec a été l'une des premières
très dur
de personnes qui à la place de vous
enfants soient scolarisés et bien
aussi que c'était l'échec assuré parce
d'ailleurs vous raconter une dernière
pourtant
bruce extérieur le verdict est tombé la
personnes à me féliciter lorsque j'ai
nous voilà au début d'une aventure qui
anecdote qui est toute récente
il m'a légué de si belles valeurs de foi
encadré
encourager vous décourage dans tout ce
que pour elle des gens plus brillants
s'annonce chaotique
été admise à l'institut national de
donc allez l'humain ma ville natale que
médecine a été purement et simplement
que moi n'ont pas réussi dans cette
en 2020 j'ai voulu réaliser un projet
comme tous les lauréats du pays nous
que vous entreprenez
et de courage qu'à chaque étape de ma
statistique et d'économie appliquée de
filière au maroc et à la limite si elle
refusé
j'ai fait mes premiers pas à l'école et
on peut encore amener une illustration à
rabat devenant ainsi la première fille
orientation universitaire ne sont pas un
je n'avais ni les moyens financiers
me trouvait un peu trop prétentieux de
vie en faire bon usage
d'une certaine dimension dans ce sac les
j'ai effectué une bonne partie de mon
guinéenne à accéder à cet établissement
autre nous les subissons
vouloir par la suite à c'est dire aux
chaque fois que les adeptes du dimanche
contexte de pandémie
les relations qu'il fallait pour faire
parcours pré universitaire et obtenu mon
à lui la place de la médecine je me
inquiétante très jeunes 13 ans à
tout naturellement je me suis dirigé
aboutir markets
de merfy ont fait irruption dans ma vie
comme quoi battez vous pour vos rêves
l'époque
retrouve donc du jour au lendemain dans
vers une agence pour m'accompagner dans
au vu de toute force
cette de preuves mammeri c'est vieillot
le cadre de mon projet
une école professionnelle qui ne me
face aux difficultés il m'a fallu
d'aller avec un ami au bout de quelques
permettaient une nuit pas d'accéder aux
f une grosse période de déception et de
résister à m'appuyant sur des piliers
fondamentaux fondamentaux tels que la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]